ils sont restés discrets près de quatre
ans après les faits les proches des
collègues de mamadou dia diouf ont fait
taire leurs émotions ils ont écouté sans
broncher les regrets des accusés vous
avez entendu des regrets et des excuses
nous on entendu plutôt des personnes qui
étaient campés sur leurs positions
salaires qu'ils sont tous désolés on ne
sait pas exactement de quoi puisque
finalement personne n'y est pour rien
personne n'a rien fait la seule chose
sur laquelle s'accordent les six mises
en cause les témoins c'est que tout est
allé très vite ce soir là le videur
refoule un client un peu vindicatif
l'incident se tassent jusqu'à l'arrivée
du frère et de ses amis le ton remonte
un coup de poing une rixe 22 secondes
seulement immortalisé par la
vidéosurveillance sur ces images
j'ai vu le videur tombé comme un arbre
que l'on abat dit un enquêteur
ils se sont tous retrouvés et finalement
dans cette scène de violence un
collective ou qui a été dans un temps
très court 1 au final mans chacun a eu
son implication à un stade différent et
de manière différente mais de là à
partir du postulat et affirmé qu'ils ont
eue cette intention et avait
connaissance que l'une des personnes
étaient en possession d'un couteau
thione il ya vraiment un vrai débat qui
se pose par rapport à tout cela car tout
est là pourquoi l'un des protagonistes
étaient en possession d'une arme blanche
a justifié son geste pour viser le coeur
comme semble le montrer les images vidéo
en clair s'agit-il d'une expédition
punitive organisé ou d'un trajet
dérapages c'est un couteau qu'il avait
sur lui pour un tout autre usage et
qu'il a conservée en sa possession près
il m'appartient pas à moi de dire ici ce
qui est la réalité ou non des
circonstances des faits ce soir là ce
qui est certain c'est qu'un homme qui
n'avait jamais été condamnée jamais
incarcérés dont personne ne dit qu'il
est violent qui a une personnalité
extrêmement atypique pour une
comparution devant une cour d'assises a
commis effectivement des faits graves
qu'il reconnaît quand vous frappez
quelqu'un au niveau du coeur avec un
couteau vous imaginez que le résultat va
être lequel si ce n'est la mort que vous
frappez si le meurtre retenu l'auteur
risque trente ans vinci la cour
requalifie les faits en coups
volontaires sans intention de donner la
main
or mais c'est bien parce qu'il a eu le
coeur transpercé de part en part que
mamadou a succombé